i'm pete soderling i'm the founder of
data council and the data community fund
and i'm excited to welcome you all for
our next episode um we're pleased to
have
uh venkat here from rockset and venket
um i need to
work on on pronouncing your last name um
i have it here i'm gonna give it a go is
that okay for sure
so so i i would say venkat
that's pretty like seven out of ten
that's pretty good yeah okay
okay awesome well um i'll let you i'll
let you fully
uh explain to us the the proper
pronunciation so that
our guests know but um vetket is a
master of
real-time data analytics he's been
working in the field for many years
um before becoming the ceo and founder
of
rockset he was at facebook where he was
the director of engineering
working in the real-time data
infrastructure and he saw lots of
amazing developments of
the facebook data infrastructure over
time which we'll hear some about today
and before that he was a senior member
of the technical staff
at oracle so venkat you've been working
um in databases
a long time uh i just wanted to to thank
you for being here and welcome you to
the show
thanks for having me really appreciate
the opportunity
so um so tell us a little bit about
your early career and um and
and how that transpired i always find it
illuminating to understand how people
got into data and
what some of the motivations were
because sometimes those things tend to
shape their career and their interests
going forward
um i have to say it started when i was
doing my master's in wisconsin
university wisconsin madison is is known
for its prolific database research
in the 90s so when i finished my
undergrad back in india
in nit trichy and i was looking and
applying i think you know this was my
dream school
because i thought they were doing a lot
of systems i was
generally interested in a lot of
different you know operating systems and
networking and
and anything that was much closer to uh
hard you know challenging scaling
um scalability problems i was very
interested but i would say it really
you know started um with like just
amazing you know faculty and and and
research people back uh you know
professor naughton professor dewitt um
you know like taking even classes from
them advanced database classes and
whatnot that was really the
i would say the genesis i would say in
the database in the large database
community you would find tons and tons
of
uh wisconsin alumni and and my
co-founder dhruba
also went to wisconsin mark callahan
went to wisconsin
uh there's so many people that i work
with uh that uh you know
root you know trace their roots back in
there and and um
so i think that's really where it
started and then i spent five years at
oracle working with just some amazing
people i would say
in the early 2000s the best place to
build databases was at oracle because
they were doing
you know that was what uh that was the
technology that everybody was turning
into to solve their data problems
from the mid around 2007 um i switched
to
uh facebook facebook was a very small
like less than 100
engineer kind of a you know late stage
startup but was still a startup um the
entire company was less than 300 people
back then they had 30 million monthly
active users
uh but they were already sold you know
starting to work on scalability problems
that was
uh that i thought was from the outside
very you know interesting and
challenging
i spent there eight years and then uh
left in 2000
um you know 2015 about
about five years ago got it got it
um so you're at facebook from sorry 2015
um back until 2008. yeah
i started in 2007 uh around august or
september of 2007 and um
and was there exactly i mean i think a
week after my eighth
uh work anniversary i left got it yeah
and so
um can you sort of describe the rough
amount of growth that you saw at
facebook um
how do you think of uh how do you think
of the kpis and and
sort of the the metrics in terms of
scale that you saw and how did that
challenge a lot of your assumptions
about data infrastructure i'm sure that
was a
very amazing experience absolutely i
think
i think you know if you look back at
some of these numbers um
i look at facebook growth you know it
was really the hyper growth years
i look at those eight years and and kind
of like measure growth in
three dimensions right first is just the
the product and
and the user base right you know
facebook grew from 30 40 million monthly
actives to a
a billion and a half right and
and so so if you if you kind of like uh
you know plot that out uh uh you know
that is
about you know a couple of orders of
magnitude like maybe
uh you know 50x is it am i doing the
math right yeah that's about 50x growth
from 30 million to 1.5
billion um and uh
and then if you think about uh the size
of the company right number of engineers
that were actually working there
you know it grow probably uh 20x
you know from like you know 100 to 100
engineers so to like
2000 to 3000 engineers back when uh back
in 2014-15 when i was there
but if you had looked at the data
infrastructure the online data
infrastructure
alone um it grew more than thousand x
right and uh so that's kind of like if
you you know was a very interesting
takeaway where
back when we started the online data
infrastructure team and
you know we had a bunch of memcaches and
mysql running on a few hundred machines
and the sum total of that
was probably a few million requests per
second was what
at peak we were doing uh in 2015 when i
left
facebook uh these systems collectively
the online data infrastructure team that
i was managing and i was responsible for
was collectively serving five billion
queries a second
right and wow that was a scale that we
had to scale it to
and there's a couple of things there uh
to kind of unpack you know it didn't
score it definitely
didn't grow you know grow linearly with
the number of
engineers you know you can't just say
whoa of course if you grew because
more engineers are kind of like building
more things uh
it didn't not just it it scaled linearly
with uh user growth it actually
you know uh because more and more
products were getting
uh built and so the news feed at the end
of the day you know was just so
um you know data hungry that i think um
it was really about you know innovation
so there was just so much more new
products that facebook had launched
uh even uh you know and then they had a
lot of power users
and the piece of innovation was very
very high and so
the collective the some of that was just
that the online data infrastructure the
demands on the online data
infrastructure
literally grew three orders of magnitude
in that time period
and so um what sorts of infrastructure
changes did you make
um what were some of the key thresholds
and breaking points
and um how did you solve the main
challenges over time
so um there were a lot of uh you know in
order to
store and serve the social graph you
know you know at a very very uh
you know high levels of reliability and
and you know performance i think there
was a lot of work that was done
you know the mysql team did tremendous
work
uh we built a social graph serving layer
uh called tau
on top of that to help scale that and
all of that but there was also this
the the key lesson or the key
realization that i had you know in
in those hyper growth years was that the
advent of real-time systems
right uh i think if you look at the what
happened with the news feed back end
uh what happened with the ad ads back
end at facebook uh what happened with uh
the spam fighting engines
and so on and so forth the the key
realization that i had was
on one hand you know you have
transactional databases that gives you
speed uh but building a large-scale data
application on that was still
requiring tremendous amount of
complexity and operational overheads and
sharding and once you shard your online
databases there's a whole bunch of other
complexity that comes into the picture
and then the big data infrastructure was
for batch analytics you know they were
basically
you know building storage optimal
systems and you get scalability there
but you can't really build applications
on top of that and so
the news feed back in team uh you know
the ad impression the search backend
team and all these
teams had to kind of like go and build
bespoke uh
real-time uh you know stateful services
uh that really started becoming some of
the biggest workhorses
uh that was behind uh facebook the
product and so
the advent of that was i think it was
fascinating to watch and and being in
the middle of it
you know gave us uh a lot of insight
into how to do it well and how also what
are all the pitfalls to also avoid
when you're trying to build real-time uh
real-time systems
and so was was the like button the first
example of real-time data or there were
there other
examples that were also meaningful my
favorite one even before the like button
existed was is the news feed back-end
so so news feed is a great example
at facebook that moved from batch to
real time back in 2008.
this was before so i'll tell you a very
simple the first version of news feed
the back end was called uh mega feed i
think so
it would go and every user would have
their own activity
and it would go and just like an etl
process it'll go and
you know look at all the activity in
every you know users uh kind of back end
mysql database
scan all of that you know plumb them
into some you know batch
staging area and then try to build
everybody's news feed as though it's
building a newsletter
and we'll update it back into the uh
into the
uh you know uh you know everybody's
individual mysql database again but they
collected all the activity from all of
their friends and other other
entities that they're connected you mean
each each user had a mysql database
instance assigned to them no not it's
not an instance each user would be
mapped to one but
there will be like you know millions of
users but they all have a home database
right
yeah so but the point is it was very
etl-based and staging
uh you know and it was just basically
completely unscalable
and it was uh slow and
uh and also it was stale by the time all
of this is done
you are really figuring out what
happened in your network a day ago
that's not an interesting product and so
uh there was another project called
multifeed um that
you know i witnessed was just completely
flipped it around and
data would get uh you know streamed into
the system in real time
everybody's activity would get streamed
into real time and whenever you want to
build somebody's feed
you just go and ask what's all the
things that are happening in my
uh in my friends and my network and that
was the first real-time system
and then you started to really see well
we couldn't build this on top of mysql
and etl we couldn't build this on top of
batch systems that we had even though
they were all quote unquote scalable
and that was really the the genesis of i
would say
a lot of other real-time systems that
happened at facebook
uh the search back and followed a very
similar route
the spam fighting engines and all those
systems followed a very similar route
and we started building facebook started
building a lot of
real-time stateful services um and so
you could see that they are more
scalable
than oltp systems they're a lot more
faster
than batch analytics on on big data
systems
and and really kind of like accelerated
innovation uh the the adoption of that
uh
pattern really accelerated innovation at
facebook in those days
and at that point um some enterprises of
maybe facebook scale were considering or
playing with moving to the cloud but
you guys were still working on your own
infrastructure
um did that create opportunities or
challenges
um in terms of sort of following this
trajectory of where the data was taking
you
i think cloud was never really an option
because i think facebook scale was
already ahead of where aws was in like
even in the 2010s
uh whether it is reliability
availability cost
i mean uh in the infrastructure cost was
like you know the biggest one that we
had to rein in before facebook would
even go ipo for example and all that and
so
i think um i don't think it was ever an
option i think once in a while
uh we will go uh you know take the
memcache d
that is available in like uh elastic
cash or something like that
and benchmark it against just for just
to keep our you know our own engineering
team would want to keep themselves
honest and so they
won't benchmark that and just see uh
what kind of performance we get
uh and i think facebook back-end you
know data centers to software
architecture infrastructure was way
ahead of where
aws was at uh in the early years um
the the real realization of that was
when instagram was acquired
and uh instagram was completely built on
aws
and i still remember uh talking to mike
krieger about uh
you know some of the the migration work
that they did uh in the
in the first year after the acquisition
and uh
you can talk to anybody who was part of
the instagram team there was a
if you look at the actual there's a lot
of the software stack that facebook had
in the data center
but if you look at the hardware that
facebook had uh the networking
you know gears that they had in the in
the data center uh
i think there was no comparison there's
no virtualization you get just monster
machines
uh you know configured for like
extremely
high server performance and so you just
get amazing servers
uh in the facebook data data center and
then
the consolidation would be massive i
think you know you'd replace like
multiple ec2 instances with just like a
single machine and then it would still
be like
it would still be like at six percent
cpu utilization and they'll be like hey
what's going on
um it's just that we are in a you know
facebook data centers would be in the
next generation of intel hardware
uh had like much better networking and
all the other stuff and so
i don't think i don't think cloud infra
would have ever made sense and i
i think uh i still still to this date i
mean facebook continues to grow
whatsapp continues to grow uh instagram
continues to grow
i i really don't think that was ever an
option
sounds like a too big to fail scenario
or maybe too big
too big to cloud scenario too big to fit
in a guy too big to fit in like a
general purpose system i guess
yeah yeah yeah so then um with all this
backdrop
um what's the origin story of rocksdb
and
how did rocksdb emerge from these
challenges and learnings um
because you you started on to be um at
the in the facebook years correct
correct so rock db was it uh was a
project that was started in my team
uh dhruva borthakura my our co-founder
at rockset was the
the first you know the person that that
shipwater and spearheaded that effort uh
and uh and we open sourced it in i think
2013 if i'm not mistaken
um so so how did they come about you
know i was just talking about
how there was a huge advent of kind of
moving
uh more and more of facebook's product
from batch to real time
right newsfeed was a good example you
know we can't you know we had to fight
spam that way
search your network your social graph is
constantly changing and you still have
to index it and search it which means
you need real-time indexing
on that and so if you think about a lot
of those systems
um the they had a you know they were
fast and they were scalable
the only problem with those with all the
systems were they were all bespoke
they were everything you know there was
a there would be a 20 search team
building the search back and there'd be
another 20
you know news feed team building the
news feedback and there was nothing that
facebook infrastructure as a whole could
do
to make them all more efficient and
faster and
and so if you think about that and one
of the
all of these systems started as
in-memory systems and they were
ridiculously expensive right they
started with like you know you know you
call this all these
memory in-memory analytics systems like
uh if you can fit everything in memory
it's every
very very fast but it's also very very
expensive
uh and so that was the time when we were
rolling out flash and ssds everywhere in
the infrastructure
and then we were starting to talk to
teams that are building these real-time
data back-ends to say hey could you
exploit flash
so that you're not just using in-memory
data structures and doing in-memory
analytics for all of your real-time
systems
because uh they were compute bound all
these real-time systems were compute
bond they were not really memory bound
in terms of uh you know so so they would
run out of memory way before they run
out of
cpu and so you'd be like could you use
flash and do you know you get hundred
thousand ios per second
so you're not going to be really iops
bound uh you know so how could you
leverage ssds and flash
uh to get a more efficient and more
scalable
news feed more efficient and more
scalable search back-ends and so on and
so forth
and then what happened was again every
system every every one of these teams
were building their own bespoke storage
engines right
well i have to you know take my
in-memory data structure and somehow
store it in my
well then i have to make sure it is
recoverable then they have
all the database problems right but even
though it's an embedded database and so
we used to have this joke back in 2012
where jay parikh my my then manager
who's the head of engineering head of
infra
he used to joke uh and say hey
oh awesome you're an amazing engineer uh
congrats welcome to rockstar
welcome to facebook uh you graduating
boot camp
awesome go build a key value store it's
like so
so he used to joke about this because it
was kind of getting ridiculous you know
there were like 13 different key value
stores and whatnot and then we said you
know
it's time to consolidate this and build
a storage engine that is optimized for
flash
optimized for being able to customize it
to whatever the needs of that particular
real-time system is
and any and it is right heavy real-time
systems are you know the rights never
the data never stops coming and so you
have to be right optimized
uh and so all of the culmination of that
is when you know we took the level
we looked at level db's uh source code
was beautiful it was amazing
and uh you know we forked that and that
was the genesis of
rocks db to build a high performance
uh lsm storage engine that is optimized
for
uh storing and managing data on all
these high-speed devices like
high-speed media devices like flash and
ssds and things like that
and was there a time when you had when
you were using other
solutions um sort of interstitially
we talked previously about hbase um
you know what like what sort of role did
other technologies be on the bespoke
storage engines that all the uw grads
were creating universe wisconsin grads
were creating
at facebook at the time yes uh you you
um
so i think there were a few systems
right like i think um
you know almost at facebook at that
point had a massively scalable online
data infrastructure transactional data
infrastructure right this is not real
time
and so people you know if they could get
away building their product on top of
that they would just do it
uh and there would be definitely some
scale barriers at which point we would
say like no no you're really abusing the
transactional database because
you're having a tremendous volume of
rights which transactional databases
can't scale to
uh and you're doing also very analytical
queries and not kind of like key value
kind of like point lookups
so we can't really scale those things on
on the transactional backend
and so when you really came into uh
real-time data systems
uh you know you really uh you know had
you know no other choice hbase was used
in one or two
uh back-ends like the messaging back-end
and all of that but um
but predominantly uh roxdb was
really consolidating all the bespokes
you know
one-off storage engines that that people
had built
and uh in no time uh the newsfeed
back-end
storage engine was roxdb the ads the ad
back-end storage engine was rocksdb the
spam fighting storage engine was rocked
db because all of them
were able to build more efficient and
more scalable systems
uh using that as the storage engine
uh and eventually by the time i left uh
facebook
even my sql infrastructure uh the online
transactional infrastructure
also replaced innodb and and
and plugged in rock cbs storage engine
so so i would say
uh by the time i left uh it didn't
matter
uh what system you're using for your
distributed data processing at facebook
if it is online data
if it is real-time data uh then rocksdb
was
what was actually doing the the storage
engine work across facebook
got it so tell us a little bit about the
architecture of rocks db
and and how it works roxdb
uh is an lsm uh you know lsm based
storage engine it's
it's really right optimized um and what
does lsm stand for
oh log structured merge free so so
essentially there are different ways to
organize
uh whatever data you're storing in a
storage engine uh the storage engine is
trying to make sure
the data is stored in a uh in a way that
even when you have multiple threads
accessing the data you know you won't
corrupt the data
uh even if the database crashes in the
middle it will help you with recovery
with right-hand logging
and it will basically make sure that you
can read and write
uh to persistent media
uh in a very very reliable way and a
performant way
and so the traditional way these engines
were built you know where
using b trees and uh they are i would
say b trees are read optimized and uh
and are made
and are kind of like a very good data
structure for spinning disks
kind of uh uh media and they're not
really that well suited for
um the the type of workloads and also
the type of characteristics that ssds
and s you know flash
um nvme and all these you know uh
uh solid state devices had uh storage
had so
i think that was really the so there's
not a single line of code i think
um uh that is trying to optimize or
minimize disk seeks in roxdb and that's
by design
it's not really trying to be a good
storage engine on spinning
hard drives but it is really trying to
but everybody
it thinks a lot about endurance because
uh you know there is uh
i don't know if you know about this like
solid state devices has these uh
problems where you can't
uh after you know 100 ride cycles or or
you know few hundred right cycles
like you have to throw away the device
and so rocksdb has a lot of these uh
optimizations built in so that it
actually extends the lifetime of your
uh of your storage device so then you
know you know facebook the bigger worry
whenever we bought ssd devices or flash
was uh
you know facebook always wanted to keep
its hardware at least for three years
minimum
before they retire it and deprecate it
the the real fear was well we started
using flash what if
uh we lose the you know basically the
drives fail
um you know way before the three-year
mark
and then and then we'll we will be uh
that would be a huge loss for facebook
so
so i think rocksteady really helped a
lot and so the uh you know it's it's a
you know it's open source and i think
you should go
and look at it and and rock said uses
that as a key ingredient
so if you you know kind of like bringing
it back to rock set um
so you know if you think about the role
that lucine plays in elasticsearch
rocksdb plays that role in rockset so it
is the storage engine it is the core
thing
uh but it is a an active ingredient in a
larger system
uh and which is what rockset is and
again when we think about
rockset uh we are trying to build a
general purpose real-time database in
the cloud
um and uh roxdb was
uh extremely useful for us to like you
know
leverage on top of but one of the things
that we did was we took roxdb and
extended that to work very well in the
cloud
so what the rockstar team did uh is is
we extended rocks deep and called rock
db cloud and it's also open source and
if any of you interested go check it out
and i'll give you one
small idea that uh that we did there
where uh
lsm storage engines manage all of the
data in what are these things called ssd
files
ssd files are immutable files once
they're created they never are modified
um and then new data keeps you know
getting dropped in new
newer files and then there is compaction
to uh you know
uh you know delete old files you know
later on and then
so if you look at it ssd files of the
you know are very well suited because
there are immutable files that created
once
and so what rocks to be cloud does is
every time you have an ssd file it
immediately makes a copy of that in s3
and so now in rocksdb cloud you can open
a rocksdb in any machine on
on your infrastructure and give it a
database id
and the data is not present locally it
will just automatically download it from
s3
because it knows where it is in s3 and
so it all you know it clearly you know
it allowed us to cleanly separate the
performance layer which is all the files
and local ssds
with the durability because any machine
in the cloud if you think about it as a
fluid resource as opposed to a data
center machine
at facebook any machine can disappear
any mission can fail at any point in
time
and uh all systems try to make two
copies three copies and try to ensure
durability by
uh you know having multiple copies of
that with rocks to be cloud you don't
need multiple copies because there's
always a copy in s3
and you can always recover from that and
so by by separating the durability
uh you know from the performance layer i
think rocks db cloud was
uh was was a uh you know a huge boon for
um for what we want but you know with
our ambitions and rock set
in trying to build a world-class uh you
know real-time data platform in the
cloud got it
so just in case the listeners missed the
subtle transition
um you basically got tired of working on
unlimited hardware at facebook
um you had this awesome open source
project rocksdb
and at some point post 2015 you decided
to to leave facebook and start a
commercial company around
around rocks tv and that company is of
course rockstead
so it wasn't yeah okay there was a year
job though so
uh everybody you know even when i was
leaving facebook like the first question
was like what are you gonna do next you
know like are you gonna start a company
and i was like
no i you know i didn't know i really did
not know um
so the genesis of rockstead was really
um
uh you know we had all these uh you know
being in the front lines of like kind of
accelerating of this you know seeing the
future of like okay the world is gonna
go to real time and all of that but
but you know that wasn't you know that
wasn't like the first thing in my mind
to like you know when i left
uh facebook i really wanted to on you
know i spent a year
talking to anybody who'd give me their
time and understanding
what are the problems worth solving
because if you think about
you know 2007 to 2015 you know that's
when aws happened
that's when docker happened that's
that's when kubernetes happened
and so the world was really a very
different place than what it was
uh and and i was very focused on you
know what are the best things you know
what are the problems we're solving
within facebook
and how to best solve them within
facebook but i i really call it like a
disney world you know it's like it's
it's its own
you know it has its own rules and its
own you know uh
you know things and it's just it's it's
fascinating it's great but it's not
really the reality
right and so when you when i came out i
spent like you know
came out of facebook uh in 2015 i spent
really a year
talking to probably you know close to
100 people i would say
uh in that year uh you know every week
there was somebody that you know some
meetings had lined up and
and you know uh talking to cyber
security companies and how their data
infrastructure looks like
talking to banks talking to hospitals
talking to like
not the the the you know just the san
francisco-based like bay area companies
but also companies in the in the larger
area um that i would say ha you know
have very you know similar problems but
very different talent pool and very
different
yeah you know uh set of challenges that
and constraints
and uh that was really the genesis of
rockstead where
it was starting to get very clear that
more and more uh
of these companies are trying to you
know take security analytics as an
example
uh it's not it's no use at all it's not
that different from the
spam fighting engines that we built you
know help build that rock uh
at facebook and and there's no use in in
in a security company telling
their customers that oh you got hacked
three days ago it has to happen in real
time right
and then we were talking to you know
companies were building sales and
marketing automation systems and all
that
and you know marketing automation
systems great example
you know internally we had ad impression
logging and again those kind of
real-time systems and rox db helps scale
a lot of them
and uh in the outside world uh
you know like i'm a company i have an ad
budget on a on a given day
and i am having a bunch of different ad
cam
campaigns and i need to know in real
time which one is working really well
so that for that days the in a marketing
budget is spent wisely right and i'm
getting the biggest bank for the buck
and now
you know and every day it's slightly
different you know what ads work well
and what campaigns i'm running and so
those kinds of operational analytics
really demanded real time
and so we i was starting to see walk
away from more and more of these
conversations realizing
uh the amount of effort and cost and
complexity involved in every one of
these companies building these systems
was so enormous that i thought we should
do something about it
and so and then we started kind of
figuring out what does a general purpose
uh you know cloud database look like uh
that is really built from scratch for
these kinds of real-time applications
and real-time analytics
and that was the real kind of like in
you know birth of rock set
um and then you know roxdb was at the
heart of every one of these systems
internally and so we took that up
and we extended that to work well in the
cloud and that was really how the
company was started
and so you believe that the the previous
two
legs of the data ecosystem um
transactional databases
um and or data warehouses
they just weren't suitable for the kinds
of workloads that you were seeing
emerge and so you took all these
learnings from facebook and and rocksdb
and decided to turn it into a
cloud-based um system
and how did how did you like how i i
understand you had
sort of anecdotal conversations with um
100 or so folks
on both in outside the bay area which i
commend you for i think it's really
smart for engineers by the way to not
just build for the bay area ecosystem
um how did you sort of quantify the
interest
um outside of the bay area ecosystem in
other sort of more
mere mortal companies who are running
into these use cases like what did you
see when you
when you talked to those companies so
the thing that
just saw honestly a lot of pain and
complexity right
um and i think any time you see
complexity
i think there is an opportunity for a
company anytime
complexity kills right like everything
right complexity
kills innovation like if it was like
when i was looking at uh some of these
companies
um the amount of cost and complexity to
build everybody i
used to say was building a rube goldberg
machine of sorts duct taping multiple
display systems that were never tested
or built you know meant to be working
with each other
uh and somehow you know and once you
build a
rube goldberg machine even if you build
some for fun uh
you can you can never take it for
granted you you know you you know
if you do if you depend on that to get
anything done uh
well you better have someone you know
tinkering it and making sure it
continues to work every single day
and then it's already hard hard to
iterate on as well right now
exactly and so i used to really say you
know that's really what it was done and
so
um and i would say the transactional
database systems were really focused on
durability and multi cross geo
availability and like
resiliency and all of that which i
commend them for yeah i mean it's it's
kind of very important very hard
problems
but that doesn't help me well
large-scale data applications
right uh like like you know the things
that we were talking about in terms of
where the data never stops coming and
the queries never stop coming
so and then the volume of data we're
talking is much much larger
than what a single node mysql or
postgres is suited for
and the complexity of the queries are
much larger than key value lookups so
then what do i do
right uh like as simple as i'm building
a
a multiplayer game and uh not even a
multiplayer game i'm building a
a a game and i want to build a
leaderboard
in real time it has to get updated and
you know let's say i have millions of
players and and millions of games coming
in every day
uh what do i do and and one of our uh
and i'll
come into more use cases but really
you're asking me what was the genesis
how did you find it i think the the
genesis was really
it's just tremendous amount of
complexity in these ruby goldberg
machines
and on one hand you had transactional
systems that gave you speed
but it was almost impossible to scale
without you know a tremendous amount of
energy and people and whatnot
and then on the other side you had
amazing warehouses and even
really really good cloud data warehouses
um you know
emerging and they gave you scale
but it was not fast enough to build up
power applications
you know yeah so so what about and what
about the caching layer
because you know when i was an engineer
the
the the poor man's version of
sort of you know maybe where the barber
hit the road and
in duct taping all these systems
together would be well if you can't hit
the database
in real time um at least we can
pre-compute
like a cached artifact and we can we can
use the cache artifact and that that's
obviously greed optimized and
and as long as we envelop the catch
every so often like that'll be enough
like when did that stop being enough for
companies because that was kind of the
the poor band's version of this
architecture that i see that
that preceded you know true real-time um
analytics
any any comments or thoughts on that oh
a lot i mean
um i you know i managed probably the the
one of the world's largest memcached
installations in the world you know
but you know i think i think they have a
huge role to play
but when you're the complexity of your
queries so
the biggest problem with caching systems
is that you can't
do server-side computation and what i
mean by that is
uh you know for example take the
newsfeed example if if you
tracked every single item uh in a
memcache
memcached key and in real time you're
trying to agree you know pull all of
those things
and find out what all the things that
happened in a network
and ranking that you know every single
person's memca you know news feed
just to render the news feed you'd be
probably doing a million
fetches from your memcached right it
would be a single sql query
right in rockset um so
if you think about how much what would
be the difference and how much more
efficient processing you can do
when you do compute about the data lifts
as opposed to pulling all these
two c's data so so this is what i think
um
the the the more sophisticated your
real-time analytics needs are
uh and in fact it doesn't even have to
get more sophisticated it just has to
get more complex than a key value lookup
you know and the minute your your
analytics real-time analytics needs are
more
sophisticated than a key value lookup
you need rockset you need something like
rockset you need a real-time database at
that point
so that is really where it stops and so
i always look at and the other real
another you know you know people say
they're only two hard problems in
computer science you know cache and
validation and naming
and so so the minute you have caches so
well the database doesn't take
responsibility for keeping it consistent
so you know we used to have this early
years um we used to have the saying
that uh almost kind of like uh became um
you know one of those posters that we
would we would have on our wall
something is like something went wrong
somewhere at facebook
it's gotta be memcache you know and and
what that tells you is that
you would waste tremendous amount of
time to figure out right well is this
product bug happening because i forgot
invol invalidate something in the cache
right so
right so i think it's uh you know you
you know
one of the the biggest in you know uh
things we did with tao in our design for
example to replace a lot of the mkhd
internal use cases
was to make it read through right
through and so you never have to think
about cache and validation but you still
get
all the the the powers of a very fast
ram based caching system
so so anyway uh long story short i think
when did it stop working i think it
never worked well in my opinion
i think it was always a crutch that was
just
very convenient uh i think i think it is
a very very useful tool for scaling
transactional databases uh so that you
don't slam them and you you know you can
uh you know scale your transactional
databases to a much higher level
but but only for certain use cases not
when you have analytical
not when real time is a need not when
your write rates are high
caches only help with reads uh real-time
systems has a huge write rate
and also not when your queries are
complex yeah caching definitely does not
open the door to a new type of
application
um like the the the real-time analytics
um that you're talking about
yes uh powered by rockset so so um i
want to go back to the rockset platform
just to understand
you touched on it briefly before but um
explain to us how
rockset operationalizes roxdb
in the cloud like what are what are the
main features that
customers appreciate about not having to
run their own rocksdb
instances so so the key realization was
that if you look at real-time systems
right or real-time applications
real-time analytics the key realization
was that
these needs to be these systems need to
be compute optimized
and not storage optimized right they're
not doing transaction processing they're
not doing you know
you know like row locks and cable locks
so so they can be the minute you give up
transactions you have
massive you know it's much much easier
to scale
and so these applications inherently
right through kafka
right through a a kinesis or some kind
of a
uh you know event aggregator or log
aggregator anyway so they don't need
transactional rights
uh but they need we may need to be able
to write millions of records per second
so their right throughput needs to be
very high but doesn't need
transactional semantics so so that was
one realization
and if you really look at um on the
other side uh
you know once you don't give up
transactions it's massively scalable
the data never stops coming into these
systems
and you're building applications and so
the queries also never stop uh
never stop coming and very very often
these systems real time systems when
they are when they're tracking data in
real time
they have some kind of alerting you know
either pole based or push base some kind
of alerting also you know
a very inherent part of that which
basically means the query never stopped
coming even if a
user is not logging in and asking a
question some automated system is
constantly
you know examining what's coming what's
happening and and alert people and all
that so these real-time
systems uh or the key realization was
that the data never stops coming and the
queries never stop coming
which means you're spinning compute all
the time
the warehouses and the data lakes are
really built
for storage optimized or really uh you
know built to optimize storage because
there you accumulate a lot of data most
of the time nobody's asking any
questions
right and once in a while an analyst
comes and say hey give me this report
and then you can spin up a whole bunch
of compute
get that batch report and if it's 20
minutes late or 40 minutes late nobody
cares as long as it's available
as long as the query runs to completion
uh so making the query run to completion
is way more important than whether it
takes 20 minutes or 40 minutes or
two hours i'm going out for a lunch
anyway you know
just make sure it comes back today and
not tomorrow is what kind of like most
people look at
and so when you kind of like build these
batch based systems they are optimized
for storage because storage is what
they're burning 24 7
right but for real-time systems that
you're also burning compute 24 7.
and the minute you burn compute247
everybody knows computers
in a ram and compute is way way way more
expensive
than storage right and so you really
needed a compute optimize system so that
was one realization
the second realization that we we had
was all these real-time data
um the you know work with almost
json-like data
right they don't work on structured data
almost all the data sets are
semi-structured
right you don't and then you don't have
and the traditional systems are very
sequel based you know you can't kind of
pass the stream past the world and do an
alter table ad column
alter table change type and all of these
things you know you just can't you know
you have to
work in real time and so the the shape
of the data being semi-structured and
constantly evolving
over a period of time i think otherwise
another very very important constraint
uh you know and full feature sequel on
the other side you know a lot of these
uh you know you know elasticsearch comes
to mind as a real-time system
but it doesn't really give you sequel it
doesn't give you joints
uh you know druid is another system a
lot of people think about you know and
that doesn't have joints and so there is
it's very limited in terms of real-time
analytical capabilities on what they can
do
and so the combination of these three
things were really foundational uh to
rock set
where it is really compute optimized uh
which basically means that we as the
data comes in in real time
rockstar automatically indexes your data
uh
in real time it builds inverted indexes
it builds columnar uh you know storage
and it
it does a row oriented storage too and
uh
and then once you know and that happens
in a matter of one to two seconds is the
typical data latency when a new data
arrives to when it is actually visible
for query
available for querying um and once it's
real-time index what you basically get
is
you get semi-structured data in json
format and roxit automatically turns
them into
fast sql tables for you so you don't
need to build any etl you don't need to
do
any pipelining and so you literally
write to rock set as though you're
writing to a
nosql store but on the other side
uh in real time the data gets indexed
data gets organized and
into strongly typed fully structured sql
tables
uh it supports nested objects nested
arrays natively
and so simply using sql you can
instantly build applications on the
other side
and uh and it's the combination of that
uh where one of our customers said like
you know rockstar took our six month
roadmap and shrunk it to a single
afternoon
and this goes back to the rube goldberg
machine that i was talking about right
because implicitly they were thinking oh
god i have to build another
goldberg machine i have a small team i i
can't maintain this who's gonna
and then they come in there they were
you know they were a
a real-time supply chain platform and so
they were doing all of their
infrastructure on serverless systems in
the cloud like dynamodb
for transaction processing but they
can't really do real-time analytics and
real-time reporting on that
and so they came into rock said rockstar
already has built-in connectors with
dynamodb
and so they you know they pointed us at
that and within a
mat within like over a weekend they
built something that they thought would
take six months
wow that's awesome yeah i mean i think
that this sort of gets to the
this notion of um that you've talked
about before
the the rise of data applications um
and obviously technology like rockset
enables company
it opens the door to a whole new type of
class of applications
um let's talk about that a little bit a
little bit about the future because
i want to hear in your words how you
describe and
articulate what we mean by data
applications
well exam well well said i think see i
think when
your queries never stop coming um
the minute you have a system where
you're constantly querying your data
you have an application right like you
know it's not it's not reporting it's
not batch it's not dss systems or
whatever it is it is an application and
um so if you if you think about where
the world is
right i think people are people
understand that real-time systems are
you know using uh traditional uh oltp
systems and warehouses
involve tremendous cost and complexity
and
and they're kind of like two categories
of data applications that are emerging
that are demanding real time
one are all these internal tools people
are building
you know maybe you're building it on
retool maybe you're building it on
you know uh as a real-time dashboard
using
you know superset or something like that
but
uh you know you're trying to build
something uh you know a you know
customer support
automation marketing operations or any
of your business operations teams
you're trying to build them build
something for them that works in real
time
right and that's one category of data
applications the other category of data
applications we see is
uh you know take chipotle or some you
know
uh you know company out there that where
supply chain and
managing that supply chain is very very
important and they need to know
which stores are gonna run out of
avocados because if chipotle doesn't
have guac
nobody goes there you know they just
walk out okay so
they need to manage their supply chain
in real time but they
you know you know most of the time they
they know that it's
really really complex and they don't
even go to their data team you know they
go
to they go to app dynamics and and they
say hey business iq team
can you guys build this for us and they
almost are looking for package solutions
that that will allow them to
track their supply chain in real time
but often times they're purchasing you
know the enterprises are actually
purchasing
sas products and then demanding those
sas products have embedded analytics
that happen in real time
and so these are the two big categories
that we're emerging and so you know
a lot of uh companies that are you know
uh you know using a sas product or
demanding uh
and real-time analytics is almost like
the proof of value for the sas app
if you're building a sas app and you
have a big customer uh
how do you demonstrate that you're
creating value for them beyond just
you know you know you know automating
processes uh
show them analytics show them something
that you only you can show that nobody
else can show so
com sas companies also realize that and
so so these are the two big categories
of data applications that we see
where when the world is demanding real
time and the world is going from past to
real time
you know it often uh becomes internal
projects
or are requests to sas products that i
use
where you're demanding fast interactive
real-time analytics
along with uh with the application that
i'm using
and so that's really the uh how how we
see that
uh you know try you know trans you know
transforming and then you know it's it's
really app dynamics
and the business iq team they look
around and say well i need to do joints
in real time i need to do
you know aggregations in real time and
so how do i do that
and they look around and say
elasticsearch is operationally complex
i can't build this on on a warehouse
it's going to be the compute is going to
be
ridiculously expensive uh i can't you
know and the operational complexity of
so so then you don't really have a good
choice of how to solve these problems
and these data applications are where we
see rockset uh being used
by our customers got it that makes sense
and how how quickly do you see this
class of applications growing over the
next
five to ten years what are your thoughts
there yeah i think i think it's growing
very very
quickly i think um you know the
if you it's one of those things you know
once you are used to
fast queries on fresh data you will
never go back
to slow queries and stale data facebook
will never
ever turn news feed into a batch system
right uh security teams once they
can you know operate in real time uh you
know finance team that can manage risk
in real time once you go real time
that's the new norm you never go back
right
and so if you studied gaming theory you
know
to me you know it's inevitable this
change because if if
you know there's a whole bunch of people
in batch world and there's a one-way
street
if you you know if you played video
games and study gaming theory
and then once you cross the street you
never come back because you like the
world guess what
eventually there will be no players left
here and all players will be here right
and so and so i think i think it's
inevitable
i think um i think this this is you know
this market is here i think
uh uh you know adoption of like you know
the the case in point is an adoption of
a technology like kafka
so kafka and uh you know if you take
apache kafka
it has now gotten every business already
used to
acquiring data business data in real
time yeah
but how quickly can they put it to work
how how much more data driven
and you know can their operations team
be uh with that data
and again you go back to the same thing
well i have a lot of data coming out of
kafka
now how do i operationalize it and i
can't do it on transactional databases
and i can't do it on my warehouse
and so data acquisition has happening in
real time
but i think data analytics isn't is not
happening in real time and so i think
that is really
what i think rockstead opens up uh
because
the cost and complexity has to get
reduced by an order of magnitude
uh you know you know we for that to
actually become a reality and that is
exactly why we built rocks it
well that's great that's uh that's
really well said and
um i'm i'm hoping that listeners get
excited about this this paradigm shift
in real-time data and data applications
and
they check out roxdb um and or rock set
um i'm sure you'll get interest in folks
um you know who watch the show
who who want to learn more um where's
where's the best place
that they can reach you venkat um they
can reach me
uh you know like go to rockstar.com i
mean we we
uh there is a uh you know you can check
out the product you don't need credit
card or anything like that go go kick
the tires and and send us feedback
yeah there's there's a live chat right
built inside the the product for for you
to give you know if you have any
feedback about
rock set itself and what we can do
better uh what you like about it
uh you know go go check give it a shot
and you know you don't need um
credit card or anything you know we have
a self-service platform that is you know
anybody can go uh and start and create
an account and get started
uh um and i would love to personally
hear from you you know find me on
linkedin i'm venkat venkatramini uh
um you know find me on linkedin uh you
know reach out and i would love to hear
from you if you have any feedback or any
thoughts
uh after watching this program that's
great that's great
um and as an open source contributor
you know the value of the community um
around rocks tv
and um so we we love open source
projects here at data council
and um not to mention the commercial
companies that are built around them i
think it's a
um an important one-two punch um that's
required to to really see technology
move forward so
we're not afraid of uh the open source
definitely not afraid of the
of the commercial side either um i do
want to ask you on that note because we
have so many amazing
founders on the program who have started
companies
um out of their engineering career
um i just want to ask you what's the
biggest challenge that you've faced
starting a company as an engineer
i think learning uh to start
from the market and work your way to the
product
uh you know because then the other way
around i think
i think for engineers and and technical
people it's so much
easier to think technology and then
start looking for problems
uh and the reason is that they've just
you know especially on the infrasight
and you go to something like
facebook you know the
the you know the the challenge is almost
already given to you you know
on a platter hey we are going to go
build the like button
this is what i think the load is gonna
come and like you know make sure it
works
and you're like oh wow you know that's a
juicy problem and i don't have to worry
about
if i build it will anybody use it no
it's actually the other way around
somebody wants to build something and
they're asking you but if you come into
starting a company
i think it's really important uh to
start from the market to start from the
pain
um uh you know and start with the pain
don't start with uh you know don't try
to ever sell a vitamin pill nobody
everybody you know thinks that they need
one but nobody's gonna buy but start
with the pain start with
uh anytime you see complexity that's an
opportunity anytime you see pain that's
an
opportunity anytime somebody says oh
i just wish somebody would make this
easier you know and if
you if you imagine somebody in a in an
enterprise saying that
uh and and sighing every time that kind
of a task
comes to be played to me that there's an
incredible company
waiting to be created for every one of
those pain
[Music]
yeah excellent well um very exciting to
hear about the progress of rockstar and
i'm wishing you the best of luck in the
future and
um yeah looking forward to supporting
you at data council um however we can
and seeing you in person two
and soon thanks thanks for joining us
thank you just one last word about data
council
a huge fan of your work uh and uh you
know data council and and pete uh
i don't know if you remember uh igor
kennedy one of the the key creators of
watch tv
i i think data council was the first
uh place where we publicly talked about
rockset
wow uh and this was probably what three
years ago if i were to if i'm not
mistaken
and so yeah i am a big fan of your work
and
and and uh so keep it going data council
i'm a big fan and so
thank you all thanks for all the all of
your contributions to growing this
community
and and and uh you know spreading the
word for what is the latest and the
greatest
happening here well thank you that's
very kind of you it's a pleasure to be
able to support the community in this
way
yes awesome well thank you yeah
so um just to wrap up for folks i want
to mention a few notes
that our next episode will be april 1st
with natalie barakaldo from ibm and
we'll be talking about federated
learning
and also adversarial machine learning so
it's going to be an interesting
conversation on a couple different
advancements
in the machine learning world so i hope
that you join us for that
finally if you're a founder and you're
in our community
and you want to reach out to me i'm i
schedule office hours with the community
a couple times a month i'm always happy
to talk to engineers in the community
and who listen to this program to try to
help them give them any advice i can
on starting their companies of course i
started four companies as an engineer
myself
and so i know some of the challenges and
the ins and outs and so i'm happy to
to make myself available to people in
the community so feel free to
book a slot for office hours we'll post
a link in the chat
and you can take advantage of that if
you're interested
finally don't forget to hit subscribe um
so that you get notifications on our
future dc thursday episodes
uh thanks to everyone for joining and
thanks again to venkat for for being
here